[Music]
in DIY birth news submitted by a deaf
policeman heard the noise oh no that's
the sound that the police DIY birth
that's like every human being [ __ ]
busted nuts all up in that [ __ ] that's
DIY dude a woman gave birth on her own
in a hotel room by following a YouTube
tutorial that's what I get for so it's
they're calling 9-1-1 she was like oh my
god the puss are gonna be ready and she
starts [ __ ] looking at YouTube how to
give birth at home and it has a DIY
music ding ding ding yeah how's that go
45 second intro yeah like that [ __ ]
where they take like their work their
channel name and they like spin it
around and blow it up I love it cuz they
get like they literally fine stock
footage and they just put their name in
it it is just like come on cuz it's
[ __ ] cool like you know you can't do
it yourself and once you run that
program that doesn't you're like [ __ ]
yeah up the production value yeah off
the production value have a 50 second
intro I love it you know it's so long
it's so long and then the woman's like
hi I'm gonna get birthed it and show you
guys how to give birth and it has a
music ding first check out my new
t-shirt line yo I saw the [ __ ] video
of the lady giving a river birthday [ __ ]
have you seen that [ __ ] I don't know how
I got to this video but it was literally
for giving a natural birth she's
squatting in the middle of a [ __ ]
Street and then it looks kind of fake
but it's some real [ __ ] but people do
that [ __ ] like does a baby come on no I
go wow that's what the drags them up oh
no but it's it's crazy I guess like
that's a thing like natural river birth
is way too I don't know but it's like
not in LA or California oh yeah our
river would be great to give birth on
that baby's gonna come out with e.coli
and [ __ ] AIDS oh yeah
and toxic waste bar I don't know what
that's about but there she's giving
birth squatting I guess that's the
natural position gonna turn you on
abso-fucking-lutely not dude are you
[ __ ] kidding me childbirth is disgust
I think prima trips are harmful
alright but isn't it supposed to come
out like like real quick if they're in
addition I don't watch it all the way
through the point where she was
screaming and then I went to the next
video the reason why it comes out so
slow is because women are giving birth
on their backs versus how it was like
done back then where you were standing
up or squatting there's a lot of
different reasons that's why I like that
I like the accelerating car move where
you're in a car giving birth in the back
and then it's like okay hit the [ __ ]
break that's like flip and then the kid
go pick like no I actually heard of that
but I also think it was maybe in a movie
my brain is mixing the dish bucket
confused a real life with the matrix you
know your birthright and they [ __ ]
grab you by the head with a closet I
have you out of this I'm like what the
[ __ ] is that the matrix bro yeah he
really said that was what I was hoping
someone else said it's I think my memory
never wants to think that he's that dumb
that's like one of you guys said it so
the fact that you pointed out that it
was semen like it's self-defense you
start to like find him attractive and
like love it because I have to like
procreate with him one last time because
I don't want just one kid so your brain
blocks it out to you yeah yeah only one
more time yeah we make such cute you
know a lot on that one story though it's
pretty dumb okay I want to hear it so
this story is about TIA
she's 22 years old Tia Tamara I knew it
the best sister sister you know how much
I miss her
that myth the bubble beam beam I used to
know in Africa yeah I like that show
what wow wow wow I never knew who was
who
all right so anyway see ya she was on
her way to Germany to visit a friend and
wander way there she stopped by Turkey
it was a layover but before this before
she went on her trip she she kind of
found out that she was pregnant but she
was in denial and instead of cancelling
her vacation to Germany to visit her
friend she just hopped on the plane and
so she didn't go to the doctors - like
for sure make sure that she was pregnant
apparently she was already in her third
trimester yeah you what you're not
supposed to do that she doesn't know she
didn't like really know she was kind of
like if she visited her doctorate they
wouldn't have cleared her what she
already fat I don't know that's it
there's some really skinny girls that
just never show and it does the baby
come out like the size of the normal the
whole show
nevermind you mean like where does the
[ __ ] Oregon school have you heard of
toilet babies though yes yeah yeah we're
fat people they get pregnant and kept up
with the pregnant it's till they give
birth it's not she looked exactly like
oh listen David cuz I was watching it on
the television and it was like it was
like it was about big women who give
birth yeah David it's 99% fat people
okay okay it's 1% are you [ __ ] happy
that's what I was watching on the TVs so
she was on her seventeen hour layover in
Turkey so that's 17 hour yeah may over
in Turkey when she right before like an
hour before landing in Turkey she
started feeling like she started getting
contractions so she ate salmon on the
airplane so she thought maybe I just
have food poisoning that's the logical
thing to think yeah so then she ends up
landing in Turkey and then customs and
everything was a [ __ ] and that's
when she felt the contractions do the
contractions getting stronger music man
stamens giving me can
actions that a lady next door and the
ladies like no are you getting
contractions to save as' does not give
you contract is he's like anyone elses
water break at this point she's already
like she and the googling like what
happens in your labor because she
finally figure it out like [ __ ] maybe
I'm in labor she started timing herself
on her on her phone and I found out that
her contractions were like less than a
minute apart which means the baby's
about to come out any minute and so she
ends up filling the bathtub of her hotel
room is she from America her
yeah she's American yeah just [ __ ] her
kiddo she's so calm because I refer kids
gonna be a [ __ ] fob from [ __ ]
Turkey no well I mean Schumer she works
at the American Air Force if she was
able to get a born abroad certificate
he's still American anyway so then she
ends up searching on YouTube like what
to do and like to give birth and like I
suggest you guys read her story on
Twitter it's really how many channels
did she go through before she found the
video the right one what about a
two-minute one that one looks cool oh I
don't like the angle but if she keeps
changing no no wait until the story is
really funny and she adds like the
perfect just to elaborate her story but
anyway she ends up saying that she um do
pregnant lady videos like it's like I
really want to up the production quality
so I got a ring light for my you know
like she they're doing look if that's
your channel like you're doing
repetitive content supers okay so uh she
ends up finally like sure you so she
only pushed about five or six times and
thought that she was like babies are
buoyant that's a little boy just pop
right up from under the water and then
wow she was like but the storm wasn't
over yet she still had to give birth to
the placenta like she searched how to oh
yeah it's another biological bag that
just comes out it's crazy
it's like an additional organ dude you
say what does it look like affect us all
you just see
white stuff rats the brown stuff all
kinds of stuff not [ __ ] though I never
shot this [ __ ] you had other brown stuff
you didn't hey you didn't [ __ ] I heard a
lot of pretty lady [ __ ] I know I kept
asking if I [ __ ] hey good for you this
smells man in that room did you did no
number one not on oh hey the sack look
like a big testicle no I just big it's
like a blood sack
no yeah no like the inside of it like a
testicle not this but that's not the
ball sack but you rip that open you see
what you could there's so many pictures
online if you don't sighs look at that
[ __ ] for night and the placenta she
delivered the next morning she didn't
even go to the you come back go back in
check by the doctor yeah so she didn't
even go to a hospital or anything you
ready for her I know she wasn't a nice
alkalizes so then she ends up going to
the airport trying to catch her her
flight with the baby not the baby she's
got to pay for the baby
yes of the baby they better pay for that
baby right the baby was wrapped in one
of her t-shirts like she didn't even
have clothes for the baby or anything so
if she gets in the airport she tells him
what happened and then Airport and
everyone they thought that she was
stealing a baby
they brought in a doctor like doctor to
check on the baby and to check her to
make sure like is it true that she
showed him the [ __ ] she looked like
[ __ ] is total [ __ ] put a needle in
my baby I wanna see evidence look into
my eyes
yeah what I just gave birth but myself
yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ] back tell me about
[ __ ] walk because my pussy's tore
open yeah yes then I do a check oh okay
[ __ ] like Robin Williams and mrs.
Doubtfire
yeah yeah Savannah she was saying that
she's amazing the Turkish Airlines staff
there were amazing they're really nice
like after they discovered like for a
night with Casey and there she is
amazing I don't know what I was looking
at the Tia and here's Xavier oh and so
cute the airline staff bought him his
first outfit cuz she took him to the
airport practically me he's so cute
oh my god how is she standing she even
she started this Twitter thread went
wrong she started it with sing hey Helen
we take that said I still really don't I
still really don't understand what's so
shocking about my delivery story lol
maybe it'll set in one day because she
even made headlines and Turkey and stuff
yeah she doesn't get what happened huh
so and here's the beatific --it she's
like it's just a baby your baby was born
into a random t-shirt but you're
prepared for it and all her friends are
like that is so t like she's pretty
irresponsible yeah cuz I'm like if she
didn't know she was pregnant was she
drinking what she started came out great
everything come out great I mean I mean
it did get a lot of they're gonna be so
much luck but there was none at all the
Wizards the coven you [ __ ] Wizards
thinking you know what kind of disease
[ __ ] a dad inside
she put herself at risk I think that's
fine but she's putting another other guy
yeah what do you say to that with really
Jews you put at risk
Xavier and they're so fed herself the
baby he came out great
he will hey how many babies are born in
hospitals their problem I agree is beef
I Drive without my Sita all the time and
I'm not dead yet so in your face you
said yet it was crazy to this GTO saying
that no one no one knew that she was
pregnant until she already had baby and
arms as she flew back home and this
she's like here guys baby how did we
make it without all these modern things
like back in the grape plant you're not
shy at all dude no but I think no I'm
talking about we the great weed I got
Raymond raised parents I think have a
sister and her sister didn't make it
yeah I've three brothers that guy before
me yeah thanks for making me feel sad I
make it fun of all that no but I'm just
saying it's to me I don't know we put a
lot of weight behind the like you got to
give birth in a hospital you got to do
all the tests on things but you know
like a lot of people do mints have been
doing it for a long time without it true
but then there's the whole breeching
thing that could happen so let's say the
baby was in the wrong position that mom
and that baby are dead like she really
gambled before she's watching a real
kick-ass video on YouTube before it's
like the baby's okay so you're gonna
pull from here you can do it like that
no you can't pull it out of its there's
a DIY for everything there's a deal if
you get the right DIY video you hope any
Niki good luck
[Music]